ground has officially been broken on the  henderson the west henderson hospital so  this is the valley health system's  seventh acute care hospital in southern  nevada it'll be on the corner of star  and st rose parkway the campus 40 acres  150 beds 37 emergency bays surgical  sites labs nursing units and more  vegas and henderson have really started  to explode in the last couple of years  and so  we want to be able to strategically be  in the right location to help those  growing areas with the support of  henderson  city council and mayor march it's been  incredible to partner with them to make  sure that we can serve this community  the hospital expected to open its doors  mid-2024